ça se la coulent douce les gars c'est la
dernière vidéo de la saison que je
tourne et on finit comme d'habitude sur
la faq homos c'est toujours un plaisir
de finir la saison sur une faq
finalement dans ces vidéos ont fait ce
que je fais énormément en live sur
twitter à savoir discuter mais on le
fait en vidéo cette réflexion
n'apportait rien à cet effet que la
suite sera plus pertinente
pas sûr vous avez été très nombreux
cette année à poser des questions sur
les hashtags cousine faq j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient beaucoup d'humour tout l'esprit
those qui voulait être le personnage
principal l'a1 a tenté une blague a
tenté un truc second degré je vous êtes
et j'ai apprécié on à le sélectionner
pas mal de questions avec lucioles ya
des questions qui sont très premier
degré des questions qui le sont un peu
moins c'est comme le moment discuter de
manière un peu sérieuse de certains
sujets mais le challenge c'est que ça
devienne pas chiant pour autant ça me
fait plusieurs voilà c'est un peu notre
rendez-vous sérieux de la défense
sérieux c'est un grand mot première
question c'est quoi le sponso de la
vidéo alors guère mieux actu toutes les
vidéos ne sont pas sponsorisé m'arrive
aussi de faire des vidéos par passion
mais c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui la
vidéo est sponsorisé par vivo au plat
celui-là c'est un uppercut vous êtes
choqués tétanisé vos muscles répondre
plus c'est normal blague à part comme
vous le savez vous avez à faire un
ambassadeur là et oui je suis
ambassadeur vidéo c'est d'ailleurs lui
qui m'avait emmené voir le match de la
france comme le portugal avant qu'on se
fasse éliminer par les suisses
je vais lire toutes les questions de la
faq sur levée 21 et je vous embête plus
voilà l'intégration est terminée alors
question de thibault qui nous dit j'ai
vu que tu étais ambassadeur vivo j'ai
pas bien compris pourquoi laisser le
fils sont meilleures avec levée 21 tu
peux m'expliquer oba thibault bien sûr
pas de problème en fait levé 21 prend
des super séries parce qu'il ya des
flashes à l'avant du téléphone qui
éclaire ton visage voilà tu sais tout et
me pose une question très pertinente que
j'ai vu revenir énormément de fois je
vais répondre aujourd'hui est ce que tu
a pour projet de sous titres et et
vidéos même une sur cinq
alors vous allez droit de vous demander
pourquoi cette question passe tout
simplement pour que les sourds et
malentendants puisse regarder les vidéos
et cette question est d'autant plus de
sens qu'il fut un temps sur youtube y
avait une option génial qui a tourné un
peu au calvaire qu'ils étaient les sous
titres communautaire c'est à dire que
des gens de la communauté pouvait
proposer des sous titres et ensuite y
avait un algorithme qui en gros les
valider automatiquement malheureusement
la fonction a été supprimée parce qu'il
y avait des petits malins qui ont
compris comment manipuler l'algorithme
et qui mettait que de la merde en
sous-titré genre vraiment diffuser leurs
pubs et ou dans les sous titres des
vidéos c'était terrible youtube a donc
décidé de supprimer l'option est depuis
bas il ya beaucoup moins de vidéo sous
titrée sur youtube par rapport à avant
et c'est très chiant particulièrement
pour les personnes sourdes et
malentendantes donc c'est une excellente
question et devinez quoi je n'ai pas la
réponse voilages explique la situation
je n'ai pas de réponse en réalité ya pas
36 solutions lumix
ce serait que je paye des gens que je
les recrutent pour sous titrer les
vidéos alors elles ne seront peut-être
pas le jour de la sortie mais le seront
dans les jours qui suivent effectivement
ce serait une très bonne chose je vais
me pencher sur ce sujet à la rentrée tôt
mais 74 nous dit salut petite question
un peu tabou peut-être je dois pas la
lire quels sont tes motivations lorsque
tu acceptes ou demande des op telle que
celle que tu as pu faire avec nos rvp
end il y à peu tôt mais 74 c'est une
très bonne question ses nombreux hashtag
à de ses nombreuses vidéos sponsorisées
me permettent de réaliser des projets
non sponsorisés des vidéos qu'ils
tiennent à coeur et qui coûte cher à
financer nombreux de ses gros projets ne
sont pas sponsorisé je dois donc les
financer ma poche et j'ai besoin de ces
opérations sponsorisés à côté pour les
financer blague à part c'est pour deux
raisons bombard là qu'on propose de
parler d'un truc qui coule en échange de
gagner de l'argent ben oui uc coup c'est
agréable
et deuxième chose évidemment il ya une
partie de cet argent que je réinvestis
dans des gros projets comme les clips
doc 6 les grosses vidéos comme les de
l'été etc
mais ça représente pas du tout où les
hashtag and je fais pour les deux
morgane nous demande avec ton métier
as-tu où as-tu actuellement l'impression
de grandir trop vite comparé aux autres
personnes de ton âge avec les
responsabilités qu'ils engendrent etc
c'est marrant tu pose cette question
puisque c'est un truc donc que j'ai un
peu subi pendant quelques années surtout
au début où effectivement il y avait un
trop gros décalage qui se crée entre moi
et mes amis et les gens aussi de mon âge
que je rencontrais eux ils étaient
encore en étude et moi j'avais un métier
depuis déjà quelques années et donc du
coup j'avais une vision qui était un peu
différente de la leur sur beaucoup de
choses je crois que pour mon âge j'ai dû
acquérir une sorte de maturité un peu
précoce fin j'ai du fossé une certaine
maturité pour pouvoir assumer mes
responsabilités aujourd'hui j'ai 25 ans
il ya pas mal de gens de 25 ans qui ont
un taf qui bosse ou même qu'on des
responsabilités en réalité donc ça va
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une phase où ce
truc là je me rendais bel et bien
comptés jeanjean souffrir un peu chiara
l'impératrice l'impératrice très bon
groupe de musique ça n'a rien à voir
avec kara mais quand même ça lui squeeze
je me demandais ce que tu avais apporté
cette première année en indépendant sans
network éventuellement des futurs
projets ouais bah la glissade queyras à
graver des infos là haut en vrai si je
devais mettre un mot sur ce que ça va
apporter je dirais que c'est la
tranquillité le fait de dettes
indépendance et surtout le fait de
choisir avec qui tu travailles de
choisir le rythme de travail de choisir
c'est la liberté aussi en fait je dirais
tranquillité et liberté chez pas moi je
suis tellement plus heureux les gars de
pitch en inde et c'est un truc de dingue
j'ai vraiment fait mon agent j'ai ma
structure je bosse qu avec des gens que
j'aime profondément et en qui j'ai une
confiance aveugle et ça me tenait à
coeur la voir ça pour pouvoir continuer
dans tout ce que je fais et ce qu'il
entreprend là je sais que clément il
aura mis à fond dans un amphithéâtre on
et conférences et clément agneaux turc
rrq men qui nous demandent voiture faire
un livre
alors j'avais fait un livre en quoi 2016
2007 qui s'appelait tourner la page qui
était un projet avec mon frère qui était
particulièrement cool à faire c'était
une sorte de cahier de vacances pour
adultes un peu chelou
et bien sachez est ce que je peux en
parler je sais pas je veux pas trop en
dire mais sachez qu'avec lucioles
on bosse actuellement sur un nouveau
projet ça sortira en fin d'année vous
verrez c'est logique puisque on va vous
proposer par rapport à ce que je propose
sur la chaîne youtube mais je peux pas
plus souvent dire qu'on le mans work in
progress
oui pop didier girl 45 qui nous pose une
question sur les critiques
est-ce que parfois les critiques des
lecteurs je te donne envie d'arrêter
youtube ou twitter
si oui c'est quoi qui te fait dépasser
ça et est ce que tu aurais un conseil
pour ceux qui sont critiqués et qui
hésitent à quitter youtube ou twitter
à cause de ça alors écoutez moi j'ai
aucun conseil à donner moi je fais grave
le mec qui s'en fout que ça affecte pas
et tout mais jusqu'à l'année dernière ça
m'affecter trop c'était trop et j'ai
fait un gros travail sur moi même pour
être moins affecté par ça parce que je
sais je me prenais trop la tête quoi il
ya plein de positif et le peu de négatif
que ya battu bloc dessus et affecte de
manière stratosphérique alors que le
positif devrait largement compenser ce
négatif pour être honnête c'est la
première année là où vraiment les
critiques je m'en fous pas mal mais
voilà le temps que ça m'a pris quoi bref
les critiques et lan sur internet c'est
un truc est très dur à gérer pour tout
le monde et honnêtement je crois pas
qu'une solution miracle je crois juste
qu'il faut un peu moins ouvrir les
réseaux sociaux et un peu plus aller
dehors moi c'est comme ça que j'ai fait
et honnêtement ça va beaucoup mieux
maintenant je me porte à merveille
nouvelle question de flows as tu déjà
fait l'âme si oui qu'en et une petite
anecdote drôle si possible
désolé je les mets dans la faq puisque
je trouvais ça trop mignon j'espère que
ça arrivera bientôt en tout cas je ne
souhaite à tous les deux la meilleure
des premières fois et protégeons nous
n'oublions pas flows un protégeons nous
attendent gérer dangereux on dirige
attendant on dirait je veux le cadre lui
c'est horrible je nous souhaite ça mais
genre toi de ton côté moi du mien laura
fall d'amour nous demande la crise du
coc vite at elle impacté et impacts
étaient projet bon je pense que nous a
tous complètement impacté au niveau des
projets en vrai c'était dur parce qu'ils
avaient plein de nouvelles règles
concernant les tournages et c'était
beaucoup plus dur de tourner quoi des
trucs hors de mon studio des vrais trucs
avec des gens une vraie équipe de
tournage etc
donc oui en vrai ça impacte et mes
projets mais d'un autre côté est ce que
j'ai aimé ce truc de faire zéro méga
gros projet pendant un an d'être
vraiment un gros ermite franchement way
j'ai fait plein de trucs que je kiffe
sur la chaîne j'ai fait trop de live que
j'ai apprécié enfin je n'ai pas du tout
mal vécue et aussi faut dire la vérité
les gens du web ont été les grands
gagnants du coc vide parce que tout le
monde était chez soi à mater des vidéos
ou des live donc nous nos stats elles
ont explosé avec plein de gens qui
étaient là pour nous et c'était très
agréable de faire du contenu pendant
cette période en vrai deuxième partie de
la question comment se passe la vie dans
ses nouveaux locaux as tu remarqué des
changements dans tes sentiments
ressentis depuis que tu tournes dedans
on a mal fixé le miroir il peut tomber à
tout moment ça me stresse un peu cette
petite gâchis il ya toujours des cartons
à différents endroits du bus rouge sais
pas pourquoi je les ai pas dégagées sont
là depuis un an petit gâche encore
freddy gladieux dans la vidéo et
l'académie des cancres a lancé declan
dos au mur les traces sont encore là
encore une gâche les clims ont mal
positionné puisqu'elles sont de part et
d'autre du bureau de lorraine est elle
la frappe de plein fouet du coup elle
veut jamais qu'on mette la clim et je
transpire très fort des combats au
bureau ultime gâche nouvelle question de
mathilde qui nous demandent veille
j'ai filmé des trucs et un anniversaire
avec mon vivo 21 comment ça se fait que
la vidéo était aussi stable bat mathilde
c'est juste qu'en plus d'avoir une
caméra arrière de 64 mégapixels le vivre
ou un stabilisateur optique qui fait que
quand tu filmes c'est très très stable
d'ailleurs même chose pour la caméra
avant elle est très bien stabilisé anna
disco nous demandent quel artiste a
réellement donné envie de faire de la
musique
jean dujardin il a une belle voix
d'accord
faisons comme ça mais je pense que si je
devais en citer un qui pour moi a fait
un sans faute et qui a été très
inspirant à plusieurs moments de ma vie
à travers plusieurs de ses albums je
dirais que c'est orelsan franchement
c'est l'un de mes artistes préférés je
trouve vraiment très très fort et j'ai
adoré chacun de ses albums out du
prochain et quels sont les artistes que
tu écoutes le plus en ce moment comme
tout le monde je pense j'écoute toutes
les grosses nouveautés des gros noms
récemment j'ai beaucoup aimé le dernier
projet de lelo je trouve ça très sympa
et raconte une vraie histoire et où je
trouvais ça très cool mais j'ai trois
albums que j'écoute tous les ans à
différents moments puisque je les trouve
vachement intemporel et poétique j'ai
envie de vous dire presque le premier
c'est swimming l'avant dernier album de
mac miller il ya énormément de pépites
sur cet album j'adore j'écoute depuis sa
sortie tous les ans énormément deux fois
ensuite un truc qui va surprendre
personne mais les étoiles vagabonde
donné que je l'écouterai très
régulièrement c'est très beau il ya
beaucoup d'instruments de vrais
instruments et chez pas ça me fait ça
fait vachement qui fait et enfin random
access memory ce de daft punk incroyable
c'est mes trois albums fétiche qui me
suivent chaque année et je m'en lasse
pas et d'ailleurs auto hkd
j'ai sorti un son il ya une ou deux
semaines m'ont envoyé cette faq qui
s'appelle ça fait pas mal j'ai pas fait
de clips il est juste sorti sur les
plateformes de streaming voilà allez
l'écouter si vous n'avez pas encore
entendu je me suis régalé
dans un délire que j'adore voilà vous me
direz ce que vous en pensez jimmy wales
qui nous demandent à quand une vidéo
ateliers manuels activités manuelles la
jimmy on en tiendra pas content une
vidéo activités manuelles sur les
warhammer c'est parfait tu montes tu
colles tupin tout ce que je déteste
alors la team aux rameurs je vous vois
et je trouve ça beau même quand j'étais
jeune mon frère il en a acheté et
l'envié et où j'étais impressionné waouh
c'est beau et c'est cool et aux rameurs
je suis d'accord mais moi mon vrai truc
les gars c'est l'exemple à l'aimer cacha
poney moi bien pacifique rivolet vue
pacific rift c'est pas japonais je m'en
bats les couilles ça c'est l'aimer car
les gones place et donc des gundam en
plastique à assembler et ce qui est cool
c'est qu'il ya pas de colle de peinture
de tout ça non non non c'est juste des
planches sur lesquels ya des pièces
thulé coupe ettu les emboîtées les unes
dans les autres et à la fin tu as ton
gun plage trouve ça trop cool c'est
hyper simple donc une vidéo jeux monde
et warhammer y en aura pas par contre il
ya eu des live où je montais degen plat
et je compte en refaire parce que j'ai
vraiment kiffé ça et je sais pas c'est
une passion que je vois là je la partage
petit part nous dit jumbo va bien parce
que le pauvre on dirait qu'il a perdu
l'envié de vivre depuis un certain temps
il est temps de résoudre le mystère du
jumbo il fait il est en fait il a fait
quelques apparitions dans des live où il
est vrai il a l'air un peu mal c'est
vrai ok en fait c'est pas qu'il était
mal c'est juste que jumbo il faut savoir
un truc il ne fait pas sa toilette
il ne fait jamais sa toilette ça devient
une sorte de boule de crasse qui
s'amplifie avec le temps donc du coup
régulièrement je vois une toiletteuse
qui le ton ce qui fait qu'ils trouvent
un poil soyeux et propre et même lui il
est beaucoup plus heureux quand il est
comme ça que quand il a son poil long et
crade où il regarde son poids les
comprends pas qu'avec sa langue il peut
le nettoyer il comprend pas donc
rassurez vous il va bien j'espère que ça
va durer d'ailleurs qu'il allait bien je
touche du bois je laime son apparence
qui vous choque c'est juste que vous
avez été habitué à le voir avec beaucoup
de poils et que forcément quand je le
fais ton de bail perd énormément
d'épaisseur on dirait qu'il va pas bien
qu'il ait tout maigre actuellement
d'ailleurs il a le poil long qui
commence à redevenir très crade donc je
vais pas tarder à devoir le fou hélios
qui nous demandent des gros projets pour
la fin 2021 voire 2022 changement dans
la chaîne twitch nouveau format sur
youtube nouvel album ou d'autres projets
musicaux alors le principal changement
qui va d'avoir à la rentrée c'est que
comme c'est la fin du covan on espère
que ça va durer d'ailleurs on a prévu
avec lucioles une grosse vidéo minimum
tous les mois ça va pas forcément être
une méga vidéo comme l'était elle
souhaite streaming mais ça va être des
concepts à plusieurs avec de la prod
comme l'académie des cancres ppm avec
seb ce genre de concept là il y en aura
au moins un par mois sur la chaîne à
partir de la rentrée et j'aurais même
tendance à dire qu'il n'aura plus tôt 2
que 1 mais bon je veux pas trop
m'avancer on a vraiment plein d'idées en
ce moment avec le reste de gros concept
et je pense que ben j'ai tout ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui pour qu'on puisse aller
au bout et elle est réalisée donc
j'espère qu'il vous plaira un jax prod
ce qui nous dit a produit un son pour ce
week-end pour interrogation écouter ce
gars ne me ressemble pas d'accord c'est
un monstre de la musique c'est lui qui a
mixé les voies du week end et où il est
extraordinaire mais par contre il ne me
ressemble pas il est juste blond et là
des lunettes et je suis frustré parce
que j'ai fait un sondage instant à ce
sujet 318 personnes qui ont voté
regarder la barre où elle s'est trop là
après si ça peut me permettre de bosser
of the week end of oak et aurait elle
nous demande tu te vois où et comment
dans dix quinze ans un truc positif
j'espère mort honnêtement je sais même
pas où je me vois dans six mois alors
dans dix quinze ans anna sauvage qui
nous demandent que penses tu de mon
haruto un pue la merde mélanie nous
demande c'est une feuille a4 ou un vivo
b21 tu attends là bas c'est très fin nom
mélanie c'est bel et bien vivo v21
seulement il fait cette ville
mm d'épaisseur alors effectivement peut
le confondre avec une feuille a4 tient
brian 2 qui joue à une photo qui nous
dit raphaël carlier tiens c'est pas un
point commun pas hein les gars il faut
vraiment que vous qualifiez votre
addiction aux sosies vous fantasmez las
de voir des ressemblances là ou non
messieurs dames c'est la fin de cette
faq merci avivo de l'avoir sponsorisés
on a plein de trucs cool prévu avec eux
là à la rentrée vont il ya des projets
très cool qui vont se concerter donc je
suis content j'espère que ces petites
afin que vous a plus que j'ai bien
éclairer votre lanterne nous habite tous
les sujets qu'on a abordé c'est la
dernière vidéo que je tourne mais il y
aura quand même des vidéos en août y en
aura une par semaine donc voila vous en
faites pas je serai là tous les
dimanches je pars en vacances pendant
quatre semaines actuellement je vais me
reposer à fond nos ressources et à fond
parce qu'à la rentrée on a énormément de
choses prévu ça va être une rentrée très
très dense pour moi j'espère vraiment
que ça vous plaira tout ce qui arrive
j'ai extrêmement hâte chez que je dise à
chaque fois mais c'est le truc frustrant
avec le projet long terme c'est que tu
bosses longtemps longtemps longtemps et
a hâte que ça sur toi bref passez tous
deux très bonnes vacances
on se retrouve chaque dimanche sur la
chaîne youtube je vous embrasse fort
merci les cerises aux valaisans
[Musique]